hey everyone
pants got to meet you in Civil War does
that take any of the pressure off
because you did you know that you were
gonna be the star of the show in that
movie not at all not at all but I think
in some respects it makes it even more
pressurizing because everyone was so
lovely and so so kind about what I did
it means that I have to do an even
better job for this movie which I think
I am a like Anna we're really pushing
hard and we're really we're really
working hard and getting some great
stuff so I hope everyone's really proud
of what we've done he has this perfect
combination of like nervous energy and
he's sweet and he's funny and he can
also like do a standing backflip like he
can like if he could climb on walls it
wouldn't be surprising I was gonna say
did you does he even have a stunt double
or you're just like it's pretty close
except when we have to throw someone you
know down a hole or something okay then
then we do the stunt double
mom always wants to do it he's like
please please let me do it please let me
do that and I have to explain sometimes
in we're not allowed to we're not
allowed to do that yeah we cannot hurt
you and there's like an insurance
there's a waiver you have to finish it
you have the wrist flick down oh I do
you do can we see it well we've working
on different ways of doing it for
different types of wet AHA I see it's
not just oh I might have given something
away there um go inside this but what we
would really want to try grab is
grabbing the wet we've never seen anyone
it's always just like it sticks to him
so now we have to grab it okay so that's
all big thing at the moment well I am so
excited thank you so much for talking
again pleasure